listen I've got a test for you I'm gonna
set up a fake scene and see if you can
tell that I am in front of a green
screen yeah he he is
but here's my question when is AI gonna
replace this clunky 20th century
invention I mean after all AI is the
technology that can draw masterpieces
and generate poems and hunt down our
loved ones and kill them so it can
totally beat out a color right right
okay I found a fantastic picture of a
happy family I am gonna get rid of their
background to show you some of the ways
that we have taught AI how to do it
I can start by just separating the
foreground from the background a lot of
fast AI programs do it this way or I can
do segmentation where I figure out and
label each part of the picture and
remove what I want if I get even more
fine-grained I can label each instance
in a segment like Sheila Lorraine and
Sheila Jr and then get rid of the wall
and the floor and Sheila Jr she knows
what she did
[Music]
AI has gotten really good at splitting
stuff up at segmentation for example
meta AI just released a new segmentation
model that can do this
really easily an AI will use different
methods depending on the job that it's
told to do but it's a bit different when
you're trying to make a really good mat
a perfect cutout
so you can add whatever background you
want this is really hard stuff see the
hair that's often the key obstacle today
a lot of AIS basically train off people
doing what I am doing now some labeling
people but also extremely tedious
separations of the foreground from the
background for one data set people at
Adobe took pictures like this went
through just like me and made a perfect
mat you can see they left out some
really fine hair here AI then looks at
these mats and learns how to create one
they might get more practice by putting
their mat over different backgrounds and
having to try to cut out the person
again and again
I just want to be clear here the AI
learned how to do this because some
people were squinting at their computer
erasing backgrounds and it learned to
copy that others have expanded the stuff
that AI can learn from by taking green
screen footage they manually keyed out
the footage removed to the green and
then the model practiced with those mats
on different backgrounds trying to cut
them out over and over again until it
got really good that helped the robot
improve its skills researcher Ronnie
sengupta and his co-authors made this
data set they used that data to make a
really really really good green screen
and then another one with some
researchers from bite dance the owners
of tick tock I am gonna pull it up now
it is like a zoom background on steroids
I especially had to instruct all my
subjects to play with the hair because
there is no other part where this
transparency becomes more visible that
and the hair and the glasses so I'm
looking at people's faces like this when
they turn the glasses comes into effect
there is transparency so in practice you
are trying to predict something which is
mostly zero in most part of the
background and it's mostly one at the
center of my body but around my age and
the hair and everything it has some
values that is between 0 1. between 0
and 1. he's talking about where the AI
has trouble predicting what is Ronnie
and what's office
and that's a hard problem to solve so AI
green screens are great right you don't
need a big green screen but they fail in
other ways
this is tick tock
let me put on the green screen effect so
it looks good but do you see how it's
kind of clamping down on my head right
here that's because these AI green
screens are optimized for Speed not
necessarily for Hollywood level quality
it doesn't look bad at first but then
when you see the comparison you realize
exactly how much information
it's cutting out in that fancy Loft I
stood close to a really textured
background do you see how the AI green
screen had trouble making a perfect
separation
got some of the numbers right but it's
confused about others and the final
problem is something that traditional
green screens can do that AI green
screens have to adapt to I'll put my
laptop here way in front of me the green
screen has no problem getting rid of all
the green because it doesn't have any
knowledge of what's in the frame but the
tick tock green screen is not a real
green screen it's trained to look for
people so it's going to cut out my
computer even though I might want it in
the shot that's a problem that
traditional green screens obviously
don't have somebody has to tell the AI
what to do
a lot of advanced AI video editors do
this by making masks instead a mask is
basically an outline so the computer has
you click the outline and does its best
to make a mask and move it along
throughout the frame you're gonna be a
car a person an animal a an object and
so we train a model just to be able to
recognize that in a very accurate way
right you want a perfect hopefully
perfect mask okay so this is Chris
Valenzuela he is the CEO of this very
popular AI focused editor called Runway
their green screen tool is one way of
solving this AI green screen problem by
having you choose what you want to keep
rather than just removing the background
where I see Artificial Intelligence
being very helpful for video and
creative Endeavors is that it's not an
automation tool it's not something that
will just replace end-to-end the whole
process it will just help you reduce and
replace the boring aspects of the
process we are seeing two kinds of AI
emerge currently for any kind of
filmmaking visual effects things one
that is very Purpose Driven where we
want to give say no matter the grapher's
actual control over what is going to
happen and another one which we want
random people to post their videos and
create cool effects we imagine green
screens and AI as switches they make
more sense on a graph of speed and
quality tick tocks might be here an
editing program like cohere and a green
screen could go here good preparation
can improve quality but perfection in
almost every case still requires an
artist to finish the job is the model
100 there yet probably not but it's 90
percent and then 90 is significantly
enough to reduce the time of translating
hours into minutes that means less time
squinting at screens
and more time in The Loft you ready to
make this video or with your family
[Music]
okay okay one more thing let me get a
slightly cooler background than this
okay that's
slightly so a couple of years ago I made
this video that's called the technology
that's replacing the green screen and
that's true it's these giant screens
that are often hooked up to a game
engine and they provide realistic
lighting and movement of the background
it's amazing stuff but since that video
and as the technology has become more
widespread visual effects artists have
been open that often they end up rotoing
even these images what is rotoing
basically it means that they replace the
background they meticulously Trace out
the characters and replace the
background once again even though they
were supposed to have it in camera now
this doesn't always happen and there are
still huge benefits to having accurate
Lighting on set but the point is simple
if you put those amazing LED walls on
our little graph they would still be
just short of the Perfection that you
can get from an artist who has a lot of
time on their hands